la politique étrangère de trump au
moyen-orient remise en question par
l'administration byden mercredi le
nouveau chef de la diplomatie anthony
blinken a évoqué les nombreux
changements à venir afin de rétablir des
relations multilatérales première
objectif l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien de 2015 dont donald trump s'est
retiré le président biden a été très
clair en disant que si l'iran venait
respecter pleinement ses obligations au
titre de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien les états unis ferait de même et
nous utiliserions cela comme une
plateforme pour construire avec nos
alliés et partenaires ce que nous avons
appelé un accord plus long et plus fort
pour traiter un certain nombre d'autres
questions qui sont profondément
problématique dans les relations avec
l'iran mais nous en sommes encore loin
l'iran a cessé de respecter ses
engagements sur plusieurs fronts cela
prendra un certain temps pour eux de
respecter de nouveau leurs obligations
et il faudra aussi du temps pour que
nous puissions évaluer s'ils respectent
leurs obligations
toujours à propos du moyen-orient le
bureau ovale a opté pour la suspension
d'une vente d'armes à l'arabie saoudite
et de chasseurs f-35 aux émirats arabes
unis
les deux monarchies du golfe soutiennent
militairement le gouvernement yéménite
dans sa guerre contre les rebelles
houthi une procédure de routine selon le
département d'état américain qui
souhaite examiner les objectifs
stratégiques des armes américaines
utilisé dans ce conflit un conflit qui a
fait l'objet d'une décision importante
de la part de mike pour p&o juste avant
son départ le 10 janvier dernier
l'ancien chef de la diplomatie des états
unis a placé les rebelles houthi au
yémen sur la liste noire des
organisations terroristes
une mesure susceptible d'aggraver la
situation chaotique dans le pays
décision également réexaminer lundi par
la nouvelle administration
nous réexaminons un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été prises à la fin de
la dernière
ministration nous voulons nous assurer
que nous comprenons dans chaque cas le
fondement des décisions qui ont été
prises
je me concentre particulièrement sur la
question des sanctions contre les outils
il est d'une importance vitale même au
milieu de cette crise que nous fassions
tout notre possible pour apporter une
aide humanitaire au peuple du yémen qui
en a désespérément besoin
le président byden souhaite en revanche
garantir les accords d'abraham et
applaudi cette normalisation des
relations d'israël avec plusieurs pays
arabes
avec cette nouvelle diplomatie byden
souhaite aller à contre courant de la
politique engagée par donald trump
l'objectif rompre avec l'unilatéralisme
afin de renouer avec certaines formes de
dialogue au moyen-orient